hey I was gonna brush my name is Peter
ba that's it alright let's keep playing
this look I got Edgar with me this time
look he's so cute it's crazy how much I
look at Edgar and I'm like that's
Treecko I see Treecko and edit and I'm
gonna try not to [ __ ] [ __ ] up this oh
my god this is a very intense moment oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] boy no you know I can't
you know if I fall I die so we're gonna
have to drop down and press a button I
don't know which button but I'm gonna
try and do it oh it's so cute
okay here we go I don't know which
button to press I don't know what to do
you better [ __ ] grab me
he got me oh that's crazy yeah what Wow
oh my god stop playing with my emotions
oh my god they're welcome pose I hope
you want I hope you didn't [ __ ] yourself
yeah I did I love you bye
it's amazing that was [ __ ] awesome
what a way to start an epicenter okay
alright now I need you to just kind of
move forward I don't know why we need to
go up here
I really don't and I have a really tough
job playing playing my favorite game
online it's this [ __ ] awesome I
[ __ ] love this it's like a weird
dream okay come on get up there body
that's why I really like to wait and
play games that I'm really actually
excited about but people get so angry
that I don't play games all the time I
just don't want to waste my time on ones
that I'm not interested in
here we go but this is [ __ ] amazing
all right let's go to the top buddy he
doesn't want to do it again there's a
lot of eyes out there I don't like it
do not like where is he looking where
are you looking trigger dude you are too
fat you're literally too fat
how big is this damn tower I'm not able
to look up it's kind of frustrating oh
[ __ ] there's another one I don't want to
go I don't want to remove that one there
it is far away
Jesus Christ there we go there's the
bridge there's a bridge we could jump it
oh no oh my god the whole thing is gonna
fall the whole thing is gonna fall oh my
god well this is really bad this is very
not good I think this is okay we are
going this way everyone how's it going
bros oh my god you better jump oh my god
no oh no what it's an evil one no Frank
that's where we should have ended last
episode [ __ ] that was a perfect ending
what just happened man God there's evil
treecko's but tricky treecko's thank you
everyone 50 million subscribers will
delete my channel on 50 million unless I
already hit it while I recorded this
it's not unlikely because Jesus Christ
my subscribers are going fast wow this
is cool
where are we this is cool
okay my sweaters thought maybe we can
wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle this seems
like a bad idea
Trika are you okay oh my god this is
very bad isn't it oh he's weak Oh his
horns are growing back I just noticed
that that's cool well are you gonna help
me okay well you're not how do I do
I really don't know oh boy
yeah that didn't work out today oh you
had here at his ear look at him uh-oh
where did he go okay I didn't expect
that
oh he's tail that's really amazing it's
so pretty I can't reach it still Oh got
it
that was a bit wonky but it works I'm
back about it I'm back in action
let's go oh that's your butthole that is
your bow don't worry about poached
you're not the first one okay alright
alright I almost fell how are you I'm
sorry
we fell that [ __ ] [ __ ] pushed it
I'm kind of stuck here in his butthole
it's nice and warmed up butthole jokes
you're welcome everyone thank you I am
12 thank you very much okay now let's go
okay great
am I supposed to jump off here I think I
am it sure seems like a all right he
wants to go there
great [ __ ] it let's just ow
we're down here now I recognize you we
went back to a place we started I don't
even recognize this place no it's here
oh my god okay well should we try and go
back or this seems like a weird way to
climb all right well what has changed
then this is changed all right you sit
there buddy I got you
Hey look at that all right now we just
got to discover how to get back can't be
too hard
if tricker dies in this game I will
uninstall my ps4 I will throw whatever
in the river okay I'm not playing around
you can kill anyone you want but did you
kill Treecko I'm out that's the rules
for [ __ ] sake man that's just [ __ ]
annoying innit
it's very strange puzzle but I kind of
like it because it's physic base
Oh perfect throw look at that alright
hell yeah now we just go all the way
around I remember this I remember this
place you just go here after stirs I
wonder if we just fell back why is my
face so [ __ ] white Brad was [ __ ]
with the camera before Oh someone closed
the door again huh no it is still open
that's kind of cool it's gotta open it
more properly hey buddy
brought guests who brought your favorite
snack is it your balls hey oh yes when I
close you mind if I jump on top of you
probably not do you think you can eat it
it's so cute it really feels like an
animal in so many way just put it down
in front of him okay there we go you
don't mind eating that would do you hey
you feeling better he's better everyone
look at that what a champ you know where
to go
always tiny little wings are so cute Oh
No
so now is it the same puzzle again or is
he just gonna go through okay well we
didn't do this last time I don't know if
you remember okay I guess uh there or
whatever you want to go you know what
whatever you want whatever you want
buddy hey ya got fantastic now if you
could just leap all the way where we
came that'd be that'd be swell
I had a be super duper uh-huh up there
okay
why not so that other Treecko looked
like Treecko used to look like he was
wearing like an armor so they probably
used them to fight and stuff like that
and they controlled them with the
technology I mean that's pretty obvious
and I suppose Treecko managed to
probably was fighting me and then he
fell down and that's how we got where we
are probably he's our like he's he got
snapped out of it or something but I
wonder I wonder where why we were there
or whatever what happened you know I'm
curious
oh no he's scared what are you scared
about
well yeah those look very ominous
they're far away dude you you can you
can do this don't want it okay alright
that's cool
let let me take care of it just gonna
climb down your butt or do not barn
that's right do not fart
I repeat I will literally die if you do
it then alright now we just got to be
careful we own kappa how do you see what
this game be without those eyes huh who
would I I wonder if there are other free
treecko's I know why I call him
treecko's I suppose they well they're
chicken salmon dogfish cat it's weird
how a lot of people just seem to call
them a dog because they really have so
many cat-like features more than a dog I
would say almost and that's the emotion
that's of a dog I feel like the agility
of a cat and then the the ass of a
chicken you know what I mean well I'm
glad I did that correct I thought I
needed to go here okay that was it
oh my God look at that mountain I'm so
scared I'm so scared all right there we
go
where and everyone how how's it going
bros oh wait charge into now get [ __ ]
there should be a button called get [ __ ]
okay let me see if I can do that again
okay that really happened then then that
made all the difference in there why do
these guys want me though that's it
really does seem something about to do
about my tattoo but yeah okay what the
[ __ ] was that oh my god
this is so [ __ ] annoying I hate these
ah here we go this is why I needed to
charge in - hey you [ __ ] off mine same
goes for you my shot shot [ __ ] in the
mouth [ __ ] miss me miss me miss me miss
me you all miss me why do I have to do
it three times
that's my only question look at him he's
almost falling over it's so [ __ ]
annoying here we go
this should be enough time for both okay
one right
No okay well Treecko had enough thank
you I appreciate that
[ __ ] finally Jesus Christ oh that's
why you did and you did look at that leg
he dead
damn look at that sexy boy oh he's not
dead okay well I guess he's not dead
save me trick
it is almost like stroking treacle and
different ages oh look at the
butterflies I just call them butterflies
hey buddy I'm back how was that did I
kill him oh yeah I did but not the
salamander okay we're going this way
unfortunately there's [ __ ] more of
them which is just like [ __ ] kill me
dude is that what's in their mouth that
looks disgusting do not like okay I
guess this is not where we're going [ __ ]
I don't [ __ ] know anymore you know if
you didn't build your temples that big
you they wouldn't be infiltrated by
giant ass animals have you thought about
that anyone okay so hey I'm back oh this
is awkward oh my god okay I don't know
what we were doing I'm really glad I'm
able to play right now
I've been added but it is very busy
weekend I'm very tired this is weird I'm
just starting in the middle of that
[ __ ] episode my boys is really dead
I've been screaming a lot okay well it
looks like we can go through here so
let's do that awesome hey look at that
we got some food for Treecko Treecko I
missed you buddy
how you been you never call any mouth I
also found out that you can just put the
nail that that's how you do it where did
Treecko go what the [ __ ] Treecko the
hell are I remember now we kill the guys
hey oh my God look at her that's
terrifying please can I have one okay I
missed it damn it oh my neck is not long
enough here so I'm not a [ __ ] giraffe
please can I have some candy
what the hell ah
what is what is wrong with you Oh take
your goddamn hey okay here today now
here's a bit weird cuz they it has these
soldiers maybe they're affecting them
look at my ass boy spanking huh oh we
did it oh look at look at that water
it's beautiful oh my god
I love water you look [ __ ] gay okay
alright thanks Treecko could we climb I
don't know that it doesn't look like we
can do much here there we go
cool whoa this is awesome whoa
oh well that it should have been obvious
what the [ __ ] what am I looking at right
now what am I looking at
hey it's me folks I'm gonna make a nut
oh he's gonna make another Jeb go for it
this is cool
forget how beautiful this game is every
time I take a break Jesus it's
incredible alright that's where we gotta
go baby
all right post shut the [ __ ] up there we
go
alright we're back in I'm gonna jump off
now that's totally how I wanted to do it
Wow okay Treecko
calm down no that's how I wanted ow I
love when you just face play the game is
like so beautiful and so atmospheric and
then you just do a [ __ ] faceplant out
of nowhere it's amazing okay well we got
another chain here that should be
obvious what to do with
I like how the game is still reminding
me what the controls are they're not
very intuitive you jump with triangle
which is kind of weird usually just jump
with X in like every single game ever I
don't know I don't understand why
Japanese developers seems to want to
[ __ ] would like the most basic things
just make it x max all right well
Treecko you went ahead didn't ya
Oh what the [ __ ] is wrong with you that
was good
ah look I found some drugs
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
goddamn it Edgar you dank son of a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] do I do it's too heavy
I'm pushing it I'm doing it oh damn you
gotta get in on this buddy it smells so
[ __ ] fresh no wait go you got a drug
problem stop it stop it
[ __ ] you gotta change the lane something
stop taking away my weight you're not my
[ __ ] mother oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
right this is going great how do I
change the tracks I got to change the
tracks I assume there's got to be a
lever somewhere oh god damn this place
is so [ __ ] dead Jesus Christ I mean
damn can I move these may be a giant Fox
yes I can the answer is yes yes I am
doing it wow that was so good really hit
it and the nail on that one I don't even
know what I'm talking about
surely there's a lever here you know
when you change tracks and it's in the
school never done that
okay well [ __ ] you missed out on
everything in life apparently why are
you still here you need to go and do
that do what you may ask I don't know
either
okay I see it now you climb up the thing
okay got it oh no you can't climb this
one but last time I saw one of these I
literally got so [ __ ] stuck all right
well what is behind tree oh I guess I
suppose we can climb tree for actually
look at me maghen his little tail oh my
god [ __ ] yeah I love I love we this is
the best it smells it smells like your
mama's ass the hole okay thank you all
right Rico there we go all right how's
the song now with the ears the track
change I told you what did I say oh my
god the track change how the hell I
never would have guessed that that was
what ya think I was gonna happen it
smells so good it smells so damn good
I'll get off my [ __ ] face nailed that
Oh still here
okay don't take away my drugs don't take
away my drugs
stop you have a problem Edgar bite nice
I love that [ __ ] alright so good oh shut
up you have a problem you need a stop
stop okay
don't take it away from me I need a hit
it's for medical well I'm going with a
weed no not there wait let us die no I'm
alive okay this is weed this is weird
for you what the hell is happening
okay we're alive whoa are we back where
we were
no we're not okay my weed my weed what
about me I'm just gonna call him in here
from now on I don't know all right
clearly we're gonna have to hustle our
way with this little thing
Hey look at that that's that was the
move I wanted to do a bad thing
EDI okay yep that's how you swing
everybody look at look at this if you
don't know how to swim
look at this boy okay I'm trying to look
for a hole no I don't see anything
my wait oh wait there's his tail I'm
[ __ ] stupid I was [ __ ] it don't
move do not move do not move Edgar for
Deutschland here we go that was [ __ ]
easy I was like I swear there must be
somewhere ah [ __ ] why else would they
give us this [ __ ] box no you moved
your [ __ ] pan no you didn't Thanks
you're not listening to me Edgar if only
I can reach that [ __ ] thing paratis
woohoo we did it wow that was easy oh
hey look who's back everybody
I don't care I lost my stash I am so
[ __ ] pissed you know it's not every
day you come across some dang [ __ ] man
you don't understand where are you going
now this is not pot what what okay
alright well he wanted to go there I
[ __ ] go where I say I want to go even
though I don't say they're ago I said it
this is so [ __ ] pretty and love that
architecture
it's the design of all the caves like
even though it's the same setting you
don't get tired of it oh my god what
just happened they're attacking
oh my god [ __ ] calla calla got him there
one more just one more
where is it I don't see it there you
whoa smack my [ __ ] is there another one
hey [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] hey hey hey hey
calm down
Starfire get up drink up please please
calm down calm down
Jonah's gonna [ __ ] stab me if I had a
nice place please please it's open it's
oh okay I guess it don't I'll kill a guy
I'll chop them into pieces and snort
them up okay Treecko that's a little far
but you go you do that we keep seeing
these doors everywhere and they kind of
they have this different kind of thing
what is your theory about the doors let
me know in the comments now tricking how
are you gonna keep going there's
butterflies which always means there's
Oh
helmets by Mitch oh wow amazing gameplay
ten out of ten you could make a
compilation of like all the [ __ ] that's
gone wrong in this game and it would
look like the worst game ever but it's
so amazing look at that [ __ ]
incredible you feel the atmosphere you
really do
okay you sit there you sit tight Rico
like Papa Pierce do the trick all right
the trick of course is this Instagram
filter looking thing that I'm working on
right buddy we gotta find four more
barrels I'm hungry
I'm hungry please find me food are you
food oh okay then please find me forward
pouch I am really hungry
Oh over here here we go I didn't see
that okay I didn't see that hole I'm
sorry I didn't see it so obvious oh mama
mia pizzeria it set up nailed it
yeah this is good this is gonna be cool
trust me you're gonna be pretty amazed
by this I am sure like if you're not met
amazed by this
you can click away this video right now
okay trust me it's gonna do today it's
gonna be hella fun I am lying 100% I
know it's gonna be cool keep watching
please please oh no oh it's gonna be so
cool check it out oh my god why am I so
[ __ ] weak dude oh my god oh yes
that's the thing I was talking oh my god
I'm holding down circle which means grip
not climb yeah
oh that is so annoying okay let's try
that again
geez says cries put it up there we go
and then grab I [ __ ] out oh my god
it's that boat I love pho I love pho
Gary merry folk chat shed [ __ ] alright
that's not chocolate pardon oh I'm sorry
it's not good enough for you oh I'm
sorry no no no it's ok I'll have it ah
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
fine I suppose this will do I need to go
there okay alright I see it no problem
got you you know what you scratch my
back I scratch yours probably it would
rip your back spine open so you don't
want that right here you go this will do
way good luck pills good luck on your
endeavors I would kiss you but I don't
think you would like it okay well at
least you realize it's so pretty
Wow alright the game wants me to hang so
hang we will okay can we drop down here
without dying what do you think yes
great let's do it how ow ow okay we're
fine
now we need to somehow get inside this
bridge so we can open for Treecko my man
my main [ __ ] this is cool on top of
bridge there it is look likes trains
went past these I mean I didn't mean for
that to happen
hey how about that we're inside their
thing now okay let's see if we can open
vert Rica oh that scared me
it's happening I don't like that I don't
like this one bug a bit up a [ __ ] sake
man all right you're gonna do that thing
where you want to [ __ ] me you're so
annoying Draco big oh [ __ ] oh no drink
oh I think you may have done a bad thing
[ __ ]
Drako no oh my god it's all falling oh
Jesus five frames per second Treecko
Treecko
you didn't leave me but I left you we
really should have died a long time ago
that was cool
that was very oh my god Jesus yeah I
thought you were dead oh that's cute
that's cute do that thing again look at
that he just throws me up on his back
that's so cool
I swear I'm hitting the [ __ ] button
what the [ __ ] I wish there was a button
to grab cuz shut up a colossus have a
button to grab you know it's a very
important aspect of the game oh wait
here you don't really have that so like
you naturally just fall on top of him if
he [ __ ] eats me what am I supposed to
press what am I supposed to press right
now you tell me see he's supposed to
auto grab but he doesn't [ __ ] do it
and it ruins an epic [ __ ] awesome
moment you know whatever person no one
gives a [ __ ] now let me jump alright I
guess we here we go
I think I'm I guess I'm too fast yes
that's damn right shut up just jump you
know it's your fault you keep feeding me
you can't do it you literally threw me
up on your back to say that you can't do
it dude you're awesome
that does not look safe though I gotta
say that I don't know about this one I
mean if we fall it's we're dead okay
okay it works somehow hey look at that
building that looks good that looks like
a very cool building okay well I suppose
we will have to end this episode here a
lot of fun playing with you and I hope
you check me out in the next episode and
I'll see in that one thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you soon
brofist
[Music]